[MUSIC PLAYING]
Our relentless stampede
towards wealth and comfort
has cracked open our Earth.
Can you feel her,
sagging and groaning
under the weight of our greed,
ecosystems severed, barren,
and bleeding?
But all hail progress, right?
We have bruised, and abused,
and depleted our lands.
Given warning after
warning, we bide our time.
Knowledge is no longer the
great barrier it once was.
Earth is shedding
her familiar skin,
and this home will
no longer welcome
we, who have squandered
our humanity on progress.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We no longer have the luxury
of tending to our own,
waiting for someone
somewhere to do something,
gorging on articles,
reports, statements, acting
as if taking in more information
will change in our fate.
The truth is laid out in broad,
scorching daylight, written
in oil, and blood,
and ash, cosigned
by the cries of ancient wisdom.
We did this.
We've run out of time, and
consequence is not on our side.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
But before you drown in
this sea of pointed fingers,
before you aim your fists
in blame, lift up your hand
and say, yes, to the future
that is now ours to construct.
Despair is not an option.
Our ancestors have not survived
the catastrophes the war,
famine, and enslavement just so
that our fragile spines could
not even break the
glass on our screens.
Stop screaming into
your boxes, and look up!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We must press forward.
Hope is the only option is
hope is the only option is hope
is the only option is hope is--
the only option
is to not opt-out.
We will not opt-out.
We will not be enslaved
by our desire for power,
our desperation for power,
our dependence on power.
But can we regenerate
this world with our power,
our wealth, our knowledge?
Our know holds the
power to change.
We can't just stop
this train of progress.
We must reroute.
We must heal the damage.
We must--
But the one thing we need
more than hope is action.
Once we start to act,
hope is everywhere.
So instead of looking for
hope, look for action.
Then and only then,
hope will come.
[APPLAUSE]